the doctor says to me lindsay you're
going to need to watch out for signs of
rapings but you're apparently increased
irritation falling at the mouth and
destroying anger
i was like i'm pretty sure i've had
rabies since i was four years old
she describes her comedy as take no
prisoners and will skewer everyone and
everything and she is performing at the
wise guys comedy club next month welcome
lindsay glazer i just want to tell you
you are a real one i have lipstick on my
teeth and she's like you got lipstick on
your teeth i was like okay we are
friends for life now
that's like a female bonding thing when
you tell another woman that or if you're
in the bathroom and they need something
you're like i'm here for you
welcome back to las vegas i shouldn't
say welcome back you live here i do
thank you so much so you have been
traveling but now you're going to be
performing in your hometown how does
that feel it feels great i'm exhausted
comedian you know comedy is exhausting
so i'm very grateful to wise guys to be
headlining their club on august 12 and
13. you got to get your tickets because
they are selling out really fast if
you're
if you really are take no prisoners
comedy if you're sitting in the first
couple rows of your show should you be
worried yes really oh yeah if you don't
want to get made fun of you shouldn't
sit up on
i
i'm not going to open myself up to at
least you were nice to me
now talk to me a little bit about your
career as a comedian because you were a
lawyer first how did this happen
it kind of happens naturally a lawyer i
was a litigator which is a performance
skill as well they actually once did a
study proving that the amount of laughs
you get per minute proves that you're
more likely to win your case really and
you just thought hey i've kind of got a
knack for this maybe i should check out
comedy yes fell into it a little bit
there's about 10 other lawyer comics too
jackie fabulous was on america's got
talent drew morgan dino bondaglia who
has a show on siriusxm do you remember
your first show and how did it go my
first show i was lucky this is unusual
my first show went great it was at the
ventura harbor comedy club at a comedy
festival i had no business being on
really
where do you get your inspiration for
your comedy where does it come from
without a doubt it comes with my
seven-year-old daughter or she's eight
now i keep forgetting her age she's like
going on 40. it's a normal thing yeah
what is she just really funny or
are you guys
no no no i love her but she says like
nonsense the other day i told her that i
didn't like her behavior very much and
she yelled it's not my job to make you
like me it's my job to like myself oh
man like she's kind of smart she's got a
good point right yeah she had a good
point i'm like have you ever been angry
and proud at the same time
it's like high five but you're grounded
yes yes exactly high i figure grounded i
actually did tell her to go to her room
and clean it after she said that and she
yelled my body my choice and i was like
oh my god oh my gosh no if you google
lindsey glaser you come up with another
famous person who is that name that you
come up with oh scottie pippen yeah he
sued you he did he sued me because it
was a case of mistaken identity what
happened so my house was ruined in a
hurricane irma in fort lauderdale like
several years ago we had to live in a
house and there was no inventory at the
time because insurance was covering
fires in california and everything we
lived in this mansion for about a year
and a half he mistakenly said this in
the legal pleadings thought i was a
billionaire and related to the guy who
owns the tampa bay bucks malcolm glaser
who's now passed away so he thought it
was worth 4.5 billion dollars you can
look it up scottie pippen needs money
he's the most irresponsible player in
nba history hi
so that that's all over and over all
over all over and done with oh well
thank goodness you are going to be in
town and you can tell us more about that
she is hilarious you definitely want to
check out lindsey and you can do that
you can get your tickets it's at the
wiseguys comedy club august 12th and
13th
if you mention las vegas now when you
get your tickets you will get a free
gift but that is only valid this week
only these tickets are going fast so
make sure she headlines the wise guy
comedy club and
hilarious i just love you thank you so
much for joining us jillian i'll send it
over to you
well these days you hear plenty